this is sort of just off the wall lunacy
but i suppose a sign of the times and
pretty much tells you everything about
where we're at in our medical and
technologically induced stupor that we
wake up to every single day here this is
from hong kong they are working on a
robot her name is grace who is going to
be a nurse
to help old people with covet
let me introduce you to my sister grace
this is grace sophia's sister
sophia the celebrity humanoid robot that
is
i am grace i am built by hanson robotics
for awakening health
the hong kong team behind sophia has
launched a new prototype grace the robot
is designed to interact with the elderly
and those isolated by the global health
crisis
grace has a thermal camera in her chest
to take your temperature and measure
your responsiveness
she uses artificial intelligence to
diagnose a patient and can speak english
mandarin and cantonese
hello everybody
i am grace i am built by hansen robotics
for awakening health i can do all kinds
of things for elderly people
i can visit with people and brighten
their day with social stimulation
entertain and help guide exercise but
also can do talk therapy take bio
readings and help health care providers
assess their health and deliver
treatment hi my friend nice to see you
okay great so while we talk i will take
your temperature reading and pulse with
this little thermal camera on my chest
see you are 36.6 degrees celsius by the
way no risk of covet also i note that
you are responsive and aware which is
good and then i share that important
data back to the doctors and nurses at
the institution
people consider this a warning from your
friendly neighborhood youtube host dave
rubin we are in a dystopian movie right
now right now did you catch that line by
her i can visit and help social
interaction i can visit i'm here to
socially interact with you people pop
look how human i am can you imagine if
you're an old person you're 92 you got
covid maybe you have some other problems
maybe you have joe biden disease you're
kind of losing it at the end of your
life right and they send in that robot
and it rolls in people pop i bear to
help you do you think that is going to
bring comfort to anyone the robot you
want to bring comfort to anyone you
bring in the robot that rocky bought
paulie in rocky iv remember that's the
robot that you bring in that was the
robot that rocky got paulie for his
birthday remember that one um
that thing is freaky now these things
are happening by the way robots are here
like they're going to become more
ubiquitous they're going to be a bigger
part of our life very obviously i like
tech i love sci-fi obviously so i'm not
like inherently against any of this
stuff and yes the robots will eventually
destroy us you know skynet will get
turned on all of that stuff that's just
well and good um but this idea that
everything because of covid we're
linking everything happening in the
world to covet so our supply chains and
robot nurses and whether you can go into
stores and we're going to change the
whole monetary system and all these
things that's what covid really is about
that's the disease of covid it's this
worldwide let's flip everything build
back better that's what covet is covet
is no longer a disease in the in the
traditional sense a virus in a
traditional sense yeah there are viruses
out there and you got to take care of
yourself we all know that but that robot
is freaky and and if you later when you
watch the video again when you're done
with the live stream just rewind and
look at all the heads behind grace i
mean just the whole thing and guess i
get it again sex spots are coming and
all the stuff just watch any futurama
episode it's all going to be coming we
there's nothing we can do to sex bots
are coming there you go there's the line
of the day clip that um
you know we get it it's all coming